very encouraging news United Airlines
from CBS News United Airlines and Alaska
Airlines say that they found loose
Hardware on door plugs on several of
their grounded Boeing 737 Max 9 planes
days after a door plug blew off of an an
Alaska Airlines plane while it was in
flight United said in a statement CBS
News since we began preliminary
inspections on Saturday we have found
instances that appear to relate to
installation issues in the door plug for
example bolts that needed additional
tightening these findings will be
remedied by our Tech op team to safely
return the aircraft to service Alaska
Airlines said in a statement Monday
night that as our maintenance
technicians began preparing our 7379 Max
Fleet for inspections they accessed the
area in question initial reports from
our technicians indicate some loose
Hardware was visible on some
aircraft when we're able to proceed with
the formal inspection process all
aircraft will be thoroughly inspected in
accordance with detailed instructions
provided by the FAA in consultation with
Boeing it did not specify though how
many of these planes uh have these loose
bolts so that's the encouraging update
and of course you heard about the the
flight um as mentioned where the door
blew off while they were still in the
air and um apparently by just pure dumb
luck there didn't happen to be anybody
sitting in the seat right next to where
the hole blew open uh if if there had
been someone there you know they
wouldn't be here anymore they would
probably be in several different places
strewn across the state of Oregon
and now they tell us that there are
loose bolts on a bunch of uh different
planes a bunch of different 737 Max 99's
all have these loose
bolts which is which is I mean the kind
of thing you don't like to hear about
planes to put them
mildly you know if somebody's talking
about loose bolts or loose screws or
something like you that should be
referring to Ikea furniture not
passenger
Jets uh you would like to think that
there wouldn't be any bolts that need
tightening on an airplane much less
multiple air
airplanes and not only that but they
needed this uh potential disaster to
occur before they went back to
check you know I know
that whenever I'm boarding a plane um I
always you know I always tried to
inspect the aircraft myself uh from from
like the window in the terminals I I'll
look at the airplane I'll do a little
inspection and then when I when I get on
the plane I look around and uh I always
see things that concern me I'll see a
little bit of uh something on the plane
looks like it's a little rusty there or
something looks so I see that all the
time but every time I see that I think
to myself well you know it doesn't look
good but I mean don't be ridiculous
obviously they wouldn't send the plane
into the sky if if that was actually a
problem so they must have it under
control that's what I tell
myself but now I can't tell myself that
anymore now now I'm wondering if maybe
they really should before we all get on
the airplane maybe they should have all
the passengers just walk around the
airplane to do a quick inspection to see
if we see any dents or loose screws or
anything it's like they do if you if you
rent a car you know you rent a car from
Enterprise they bring you out to the lot
and then they have you do a little
circle around the car uh to check for
damage so maybe we need to do that with
planes too I don't
know because they don't seem to be
picking up on this stuff on their own or
even worse even worse they are picking
up on it and they do know about some of
these problems but uh they're not doing
anything about it so here's a
spokeswoman with the national
Transportation safety
board uh she gave a press conference
yesterday about all this and and and
here's something that she said
listen now our systems group uh began
looking at all the aircraft systems they
documented the entire flight deck and
they asked about the the auto
pressurization fail light that did
illuminate in three previous flights
there was a decision by Alaska Airlines
to um a restriction actually they put in
place they called an eops restriction
that uh prevented that plane uh from
being flown to Hawaii over uh water so
that it could if some if some light did
illuminate it could return very quickly
to an airport okay wait um hang on here
just one second so Alaska knew that the
plane had press pressurization
problems and rather than send the plane
in for
repairs they in decided instead to just
not fly it over
water I mean how is this not a major
Scandal they said yeah there might be an
issue which is just don't take it over
water and it'll be fine I mean think
about that for a second think about how
you would
feel if you were getting on a plane and
you knew about like if they told
you if the captain came on the the
intercom and said ladies and gentlemen
uh expecting a smooth flight this
evening everything looks good uh just as
long as we don't fly over any large
bodies of water everything should be
fine and uh also as long as you're not
sitting sitting next to the doors then
then we expect everything to be fine we
just need to be able to land this puppy
you know in a split second if we need
to it really is amazing have you noticed
that big tech companies are masquerading
as privacy companies they'll tell you to
just fix your privacy settings turn off
app tracking and you're all good right
are we supposed to believe that the big
bad Tech wolf has now turned into our
sweet Grandma big Tech feeds on your
information sure maybe they'll release a
feature now and then that does some good
but collecting and selling off your data
is in big Tech's nature it's what they
do they can't stop themselves from
looking at what you do on online so
that's why to protect yourself against
big Tech prying eyes I use expressvpn
when you use the expressvpn app on your
computer or phone you're hiding your
unique IP address so that websites can't
use that address to find out your real
location or track what you do online on
top of that expressvpn encrypts and
reroutes 100% of your online activity so
your internet provider Wi-Fi admin and
hackers cannot see the best part though
is how easy it is to use it just takes
one click to protect all your devices
Plus one expressvpn subscription covers
up to five devices at the same time so
you can protect your entire family too
that's why expressvpn is rated number
one by uh CNET wired tech radar and
countless others today's the day get the
VPN that I trust to protect my online
privacy when Big Bad Tech is at the door
visit expressvpn.com Walsh and you can
get an extra three months free on a
one-year package that's
expressvpn.com Walsh expressvpn.com
Walsh to learn more it's like Alaska
Airlines was basically
acting was acting like me 15 years ago
when I was broke and uh and I had a and
my a tire blew out I put the spare on
and I was riding around on the spare for
three months because I couldn't afford
to get a tire and anytime somebody got
in the car with me I would just tell
them it's like everything's probably
fine I just I can't go over 50 miles an
hour and I don't go on highways in this
thing because I you know in case
anything
happens but you would hope that
commercial airline companies would be a
little more respons responsible than I
was when I was a broke 22-year-old but
they're not and keep in
mind here to me is the real point of
this is you keep in mind what you
heard um on this show a few weeks ago
remember it was like three weeks ago
when I did a monologue on the show where
I warned you that we are heading towards
some major airline
disasters and and in the three weeks
since I said that there was was a a
collision of a passenger aircraft on a
on a runway in Japan that was a couple
weeks ago and then you have a a hole
being blown open in the side of a plane
while it's at cruising
altitude that's just in the three weeks
since I said
that so we are and neither of those are
the major I mean the Collision of the
plane could have been a major disaster
fortunately it wasn't as bad in terms of
uh in casualties as it could have been
so we we have not had the major disaster
yet but we are well on our way and I I
normally enjoy saying I told you so but
when it comes to this I'm not going to
enjoy saying it um I don't want to be
right but I am
because it and it's not like I this is
not some kind of prophecy on my part
it's just that it's clear when you look
at the situation that the competence and
quality and skill level in the airline
industry has dropped dramatically over
the past 20 years and especially over
the past 10 and that's happening in
every major industry and including the
airline
industry um and why is that happening
well there there really actually
multiple cultural factors that uh play
into that but the number one culprit is
Dei diversity we've got to diversify the
ranks too many white men uh we got to
get more people involved which doesn't
mean okay and of course every time I say
this uh you always have idiots that hear
this oh you're saying that a black
person can never fly no it's once you
start emphasizing in the hiring process
anything but Merit and skill and
competence when anything at all comes
above that in the hiring process in any
industry especially the airline industry
for God's sake but when that
happens bad things
follow and and so that's it you don't
need to be an astronomist to to predict
that it's just it it will happen it's
it's it's
inevitable um and
so yeah we're well on our way I hate to
say especially as someone who still
flies all the time I I very much um wish
this was not the case but it is if You'
like to see what else I have to say you
can access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there God speed